I'm back in Connecticut to see my
daughters because I'm here to help aniko
pack up and get ready for Arizona for
college I want to have one last mommy
and daughter day so I want to take them
to a place that be Stefan all together
when they were younger
yes you are yeah you are there's an
inflation where do you fall
down there
I don't know if I can do this you guys I
don't know don't be a party pooper
mom's just a chicken and she never wants
to do anything fun and I just really
want her to do a little parkour today
she like freaks out over like the
smallest things he's like a
hypochondriac
[Music]
yeah you did it
now beat that it's like dine and dash
baby dine and dash
okay job
I definitely don't want to get pummeled
to death by this swinging arm of hell I
don't even know what it is
hope I don't fall and papa boo but maybe
these will save me
dude dude dude oh my God why
keep going okay go go go go go go go go
go
[Laughter]
my mom's core balanced very off I think
it's the boobs she just stood there she
was like ah
I feel like in movies or they fall off
buildings so you're like
just a sight to see honestly
let's jump over here oh okay
oh oh your boobs are in my face
[Music]
I have camel toe ow
foreign
[Music]